SPEAKER 1: Welcome, everyone.
We're extremely pleased today
to have with us Mingming Yang.
Mingming received her PhD from
the MIT physics department
last September.
She was part of a team
of various scientists
who were responsible for
their work on the Large Hadron
Collider for the discovery
of the Higgs boson.
Mingming worked on searching
for the Higgs boson
through its photon decay
at the LHC in CERN, which
is the European Organization
for Nuclear Research.
Since then, Mingming has been
traveling around the world,
sharing her story and meeting
with different people.
We are so delighted to
have her with us today
to share her experiences and
take us through her journey.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MINGMING YANG: Thank you very
much for the introduction.
Good afternoon, everyone.
This is a very colorful
stage, and my heart
is beating a little bit fast.
I'm Mingming Yang.
Last summer, I
submitted my PhD thesis
to the MIT physics department
about the discovery
of the Higgs boson, and the
measurements of its properties
through the two-photon decay.
And I have been
traveling since then.
I'm writing a story on the road.
This story is not just
about science, but also
about people behind this
scientific discovery.
There's a huge beauty
in the human activities
that I experienced through
the search of the Higgs boson,
and I would like to deliver it
to more people in the world.
The name of the story
is "The Discovery,"
and I would like to tell
the story to you today.
So do not worry if you do not
understand all the details.
It's just like me
looking at a painting
or listening to
a piece of music.
I don't necessarily
understand all the details,
but I can still
feel it as a whole.
So please do not leave
before I finish the story.
And please feel it.
OK, are you ready?
Let me start from the night when
we first unblinded the Higgs
search result. The night
before June 15, 2012,
I started writing
down blinding slides.
My teammates, Fabian Stokely,
postdoctoral researcher
from Switzerland,
and Josh Bendavid,
senior graduate
student from Canada,
continued working
towards the final plots.
Meanwhile, our colleagues
on another team,
students and researchers
of several institutes
from different countries,
are working independently
towards the same goal.
This was going to be a sleepless
night for the searchers,
the working group of
the CMS experiment
at the Large Hadron Collider
of European Organization
for Nuclear Research,
searching for the Higgs boson
through its decay
into two photons.
About one quarter century
ago before this June
night, my life started in
19-- one of the Asian capitals
in China.
My name is Mingming.
In Chinese, Ming
equals to [INAUDIBLE],
both associated with light.
Since the particle of
light is called photon,
if you want you can also
call me photon photon.
I don't think my parents
gave me this name in order
to encourage me to search for
Higgs boson through its decay
into two photons,
because my parents have
no idea what is a Higgs boson.
But I do thank
them for giving me
a happy childhood with
little constraint,
and letting me grow
freely into myself.
When I was 13 years
old, every weekday
I walked between my home
and my middle school,
40 minutes in the morning,
40 minutes in the afternoon.
On the road, I think about
various kinds of questions.
What score would I get
for the [INAUDIBLE] exam?
What to eat tonight?
I usually ran out of such daily
life questions about halfway,
and ended up
thinking about, what
is the fundamental
nature of the world?
Why do we do this?
I don't think I
reached any conclusions
on those profound questions
on that road at that time.
But I suspected thinking
about those questions
somehow transported me
to a particular space
at a particular time.
To unblind the search
results of the Higgs
boson along with my colleagues.
And this result is
crucial to answer
one of the fundamental questions
of the particle physics--
what is origin of mass?
At this moment, the standard
model of particle physics
has survived all the
experimental tests
since its foundation
about a half century ago
The standard model is
a theory endeavoring
to describe all matter and
all forces in the universe
except for gravity.
[INAUDIBLE] are
fundamental particles.
How fundamental is fundamental?
Is an atom considered as
a fundamental particle?
The answer is no, because when
we look closely into an atom,
we see it is actually made
up of a particle called
proton, surrounded by another
particle called the electron.
And when we look
further into the proton,
we see it is made up of three
particles called quarks.
However, when we look as
closely as we can into the quark
and electron, we do not
see any subparticle inside,
and electrons and
quarks are considered
as fundamental particles.
According to the standard model,
all the fundamental particles
are originally massless, like
photons, the particle carrying
electromagnetic force, also
known as a particle of light,
whose speed in space-time is
the maximum allowed speed,
the speed of light.
However, a hypothetical
field permitting over space
and through time, and
this lightness of being,
and it interacts with
the fundamental particles
like water dragging down the
fish from the swimming of speed
of light.
And it gives mass to the
fundamental particles,
which leads to the
formation of structures--
the stars, Earth, mountains,
and we human beings.
To prove the existence of
this field generating mass
that underlies other
existence, the observation
of the rip of the field, that
last undetected fundamental
particle, also called a
Higgs boson, was a key.
Generations of experimental
particle physicists
have been searching
for the Higgs boson,
but no evidence is found.
The mass of the Higgs boson
is unknown except for a rough
larger bound, upper bound.
And the possibility of low
Higgs mass is excluded.
Why the Higgs boson is so
difficult to be detected?
First, it is very
difficult to be produced.
The Higgs boson is
expected to be produced
from the collision between
a pair of particles,
for example protons, where
the original particles are
destroyed, and their
energies are converted
to the mass of a Higgs boson.
The Higgs boson
has a large mass.
That means it needs large
energy to be produced.
And even if energy is
enough, the production rate
of the Higgs boson
is extremely low,
about one out of
billions of collisions.
Therefore a very
powerful collider
is needed to provide
intense proton beams
and bring them into
connections at a speed
almost the speed
of light in order
to create the Higgs boson in
a reasonable amount of time.
Second, even if the
Higgs boson is produced,
it decays immediately into
different types of particles,
and only these
decaying particles
can be detected given a
comprehensive detector
to identify different
types of particles
and measure their energies
and moving directions.
An enormous amount of
background collisions,
which does not produce
the Higgs boson,
but the particles either
exactly the same or very similar
to the Higgs decay.
And the physicists have to
analyze the data collected
from millions of
billions of collisions
in order to illuminate
the statistical evidence
of the Higgs boson.
Finally, the Large Hadron
Collider is constructed.
The Large Hadron Collider
is a 27-kilometer ring
underneath the area between
Geneva Lake and Jura Mountains,
and it is designed to
collide two beams of protons
at energies up to 14 TeV,
where one TeV equals 1,000 GeV,
and 1 GeV is about
the mass of a proton.
This collision
energy if seven times
that of the previous-- highest
energy of the previous most
powerful collider.
And the construction of
the Large Hadron Collider,
along with its two largest
experiments, CMS and Atlas,
essentially are
proving or excluding
the existence of
the Higgs boson.
Both experiments have a
giant cylindrical detector,
thousands of meters in
length and half that length
in diameter.
And a collaboration of thousands
of physicists and engineers
are all over the world.
Each experiment is to conduct
an independent Higgs search
through particle search
channels over a wide range
of possible Higgs mass.
And each search channel is
to search for the Higgs boson
through a particular
type of the Higgs decay,
which is sensitive to a certain
range of the Higgs mass.
In 2011, when the Large
Hadron Collider just
ramped up the rate of
proton-proton collisions
at the energy of 7
TeV, I came to CERN
to work on my PhD thesis,
searching for the Higgs boson
through the two-proton channel.
Well, after five main search
channels of the Higgs boson,
along with my teammates from
MIT and other colleagues
within the Higgs to two-photon
working group of the CMS
experiment, by
analyzing the data
collected from
this sim detector.
This plot shows you a collision
event producing two photons
and caught by the detector
where the blue cylindrical area
represents the detector, called
electromagnetic calorimeter
made of tens of
thousands of crystals,
and the two red bars
represent the energy deposit
of the photons
into the detector.
The two-photons channel looks
for two energetic photons
from the Higgs decay.
And it is one of the
most promising channels
for the Higgs discovery when
the Higgs mas is relatively low,
between 110 GeV and the 150 GeV.
Thanks to the electromagnetic
calorimeter, photons
can be clearly identified.
Furthermore, their
energies could
be mirrored with excellent
resolution, from which
a quantity called two-photon
mass can be reconstructed
precisely for each photon pair.
And this allows us constructing
a characteristic spectrum
of the two-photon mass of
the identified photon pairs,
as shown on the right plot.
In this spectrum, a signal peak
due to a Higgs boson centered
on the Higgs mass, with
its width determined
to by the two-photon
mass resolution,
will sit on top of a
smoothly falling slope
of the background, which
would give persuasive evidence
if the Higgs boson exists.
Despite the appealing
feature of the signal peak,
the Higgs boson actually
does not quite frequently
decay to two photons.
How rare is a two-photon decay?
It is about one out of hundreds
of the decay of already
rarely produced Higgs bosons.
So the great challenge
facing this search channel
is to identify this small
peak from the large background
underneath.
Facing this challenge, we
developed nice strategy
to classify the photon pairs.
The ones more likely
from the Higgs decay
and have better
mass resolution are
selected into a
higher-ranking class, which
will have a sharper peak
in the mass spectrum
and add more sensitivity
to the Higgs signal.
Finally, we extract the signal
by comparing the observed
spectra of all the classes
with models of expected signal
plus background spectrum.
If any excess of the photon
pairs above the background
expectation is observed, we
estimate the significance
of the excess, as shown
on the right plot.
The black curve
shows a probability
that the observed excess
is due to the fluctuation
of the background.
If the lowest
probability is about one
out of 1,000, corresponding to a
significance about three sigma,
we say there is evidence
of a new particle.
And if the probability is
about dozens out of a million,
corresponding to
four sigma, we say
there's convincing evidence.
And if the probability reaches
1 out of 3 and 1/2 million,
corresponding to five sigma,
we claim the discovery
of a new particle.
OK, it takes a couple minutes
to say, however years to do.
In order to reach the
final mass spectrum,
we need to go through
many steps in analysis
from the photon identification,
photon energy reconstruction,
photon direction
of reconstruction,
and the photon pair
classification.
This plot gives you an example
of the observed mass spectrum
from one of the classes.
The black data points
show the observed number
of pairs of photons
as a function
of the two-photon mass.
And the red curve is the
distribution of signal
plus background fit
to the observed data.
If the Higgs boson
exists, we would
expect to see an
excess of photon pairs
as shown like this data point
jumping from the background--
smoothly falling background.
By analyzing the 2011
data, we observed
an excess of photon pairs above
the background expectation.
Another channel in
the CMS experiment,
the [INAUDIBLE] search channel,
also observed an excess,
but not as significant.
And the combined excess
at the CMS experiment
is dominated by the excess
from the two-photon channel.
A similar excess
is also observed
at the Atlas
experiment, dominated
by the excess of its
two-photon channel as well.
To determine the
source of this excess,
whether it is from
the background
fluctuation or a real signal,
the analysis of the 2012 data
is critical.
We improved our analysis, and
we optimized it to accommodate
the enhanced energy to 8 TeV.
And to avoid any possibility to
bias the results-- for example,
artificially create a
peak in a spectrum--
we do the analysis in a
strictly blind manner.
That means we do not
look at the signal
region in the mass spectrum
between 110 GeV to 150 GeV
until our analysis is
fully fixed and verified.
And all the other Higgs
search channels also
progressed under the blind.
Finally, we reached this
night before June 15, 2012.
In order to reach this night, we
had gone through many sleepless
nights working on analysis
through the development
of different kinds of
components of the analysis,
to multiple rounds
of producing results
to keep updated with the
increased data and improved
calibration of the detector.
We had multiple teams in
the Higgs two-photon working
group, each team running an
independent analysis framework.
Those teams had also gone though
constructive, while sometimes
fierce competitions on
the analysis methods,
but ultimately strove together
for the final results.
To finalize the analysis
for the unblinding
and to synchronize
among different teams
equals to a huge effort
of the entire group.
And finally, two
teams synchronized
to a satisfactory level.
Each team was going to produce
a set of unblinded results
to cross check.
Among all the teams,
the MIT two-photon team
is a small team known for
all coffee and no sleep.
Our coffee machine
works so hard,
and it was finally broken.
As a result, our
proposed method was
determined by the group as
the main analysis method.
Besides the coffee machine,
working with me day and night
are my teammates.
So this guy with
the exploding hair
is Josh Bendavid, senior
graduate student from Canada.
Josh effectively worked
24 hours every day.
Whenever I needed discussion--
2:00 AM, 3:00 AM, 4:00 AM, 5:00
AM, Josh is always there
online or on the phone,
and our conversations
can write a book
about 1,000 pages all about
the search for the Higgs boson.
And this guy, he looks very shy.
He is Fabian Stokely,
postdoctoral researcher
from Switzerland.
And Fabian always wears
the same black tee shirt.
And this guy is Christoph Paus,
my PhD supervisor from Germany.
And he flies between MIT
and CERN every other week.
You might think, where's me?
So this is me in the window.
And I have to admit
that I didn't have time
to brush teeth for months,
and I no longer care.
There is dozens more
colleagues from MIT
working on different Higgs
search channels, detector
or computing.
And they didn't care whether
I brushed teeth either.
Well, you might want to ask, how
do you think about these days?
There are [INAUDIBLE],
difficult to say.
I wish I had invited
you to my office
at CERN Building
32, fourth floor.
There's not much room, and if
you come during the summer,
there's no air conditioner.
And my desk is so small,
it can hold nothing
but a few books and a laptop.
However, look
through the window.
This is the view
that you can see.
And listen to the music that
[INAUDIBLE] the corridor.
And what I want to say can be
summarized as the following.
Late night, look deep into
the sky, turn on music loudly,
loudly, and sing along.
Good time to free the
soul and face the unknown.
As the night was
progressing, Christoph
was about to catch
another flight.
Having fixed some problem
in our computer cluster
at MIT, important for producing
the final analysis results,
Christoph was flying to
CERN for the unblinding
event in the coming
afternoon, the event
that unblinded search
results from all the channels
were presented to the
entire CMS collaboration
for the first time.
I wrote down my memory
about that night.
And the unblinding went in the
coming afternoon into my story.
And I'd like to share
a little bit with you.
I stayed in a room
of the CERN hostel
last night, within three
minutes walk from my office,
40 minutes walk from my studio
in St. Saint-Genis-Pouilly,
a small town at the foot
of the Jura Mountains.
The past couple
weeks was so intense
that I almost live at CERN, with
few hours of sleep at the task,
and 10 cups of coffee
many of the days.
And since there was
almost no time to eat,
there was no need
to brush teeth.
Extremely tired, but
also extremely excited,
I wrote down the slide-- title--
search for a standard model
Higgs boson decaying to
two photons, unblinding.
Representing the Higgs to
two-photon working group,
I was going to unblind our
Higgs search results to the CMS
collaboration in the coming
afternoon, the results still
sitting in the dark
waiting to be uncovered.
During the past year, I was
used to missing the last bus
at 1:00 AM from CERN
to Saint-Genis-Pouilly
and walking back along the
Jura Mountains onto the night.
Sometimes the analysis
work got so busy
that even such a walk
was not affordable.
Instead, I would stay at a desk
in my office over the night,
or move to the CERN hostel
during the critical times,
like this night, expecting
a couple of hours rest
on the bed to refresh, but
still remaining at the desk
the entire night.
The staff at the
CERN hostel was used
to my unexpected
interruptions and being
able to find me a room.
But no single room was
left for this night.
All available was a double room.
I paid for the room
without hesitation,
not because I was rich.
There was not much left of
a graduate student's center
salary after paying the
rent, meal, and coffee.
But the chance to work
together with these people,
in this space, at this
time, towards these results,
was only once.
Even if I had to die
for the moment, I'd die.
Everything else
is out of concern.
The night deepened, floating
all the sleepless nights
into the dark sky
towards the unknown.
The slides grow within
the analysis descriptions
and the validation plots,
reaching the black room
for the final plots.
The last round of cross checks
started between the two teams,
with information flowing
through an email thread.
Finally, the expected results
and the yields of photon pairs
agreed.
Time to look into
the signal region.
Around 3:00 AM, both teams
unblinded the two-photon mass
spectrum of the 2012
data-- clear excess jumping
from the falling spectra of
multiple classes around 125
GeV, about the same place
of the excess that we
observed from the 2011 data.
A real signal is there.
It was not spoken
out, but I heard
the yells bursting out from
the huts at different ends.
Enormous excitement flowed out,
permeating silently in the air.
I looked out through
the window into the sky
with the speed of
light, but in the end,
stood together with the
Grand Jura Mountains
quietly upon the ground
watching the pairs
of photons passing through
the light years of nights.
Later in the morning,
we had a quick gathering
together with more
colleagues from the Higgs
to two-photon working group in
a small meeting room at CERN.
Everybody looked
extremely excited,
despite not sleeping much.
We tried not to speak
loudly, since we
had to keep the secret
until the unblinding
event in the afternoon.
Still more plots to make.
We soon went back to
work, with more colleagues
from different teams
joining to help.
At this time, all of the
huts were bumped together.
I kept modifying the slides with
suggestions from my colleagues,
while new plots continually come
of various statistical results
or two-photon mass spectra being
updated with final granularity
or refined style.
As time approached
the unblinding event,
I started putting the
final version of the plots
from my colleagues
onto the page, one
after another, each
plot a great trust
falling silently upon my hut.
Time passes 3:00 PM.
I finally finished the
slides, with the last plot
just assigned from Fabian.
Our other colleagues,
after their super
quick and collaborative
effort, had
left earlier to the
unblinding event, which
had already started at the
CERN building called Filtration
Plant.
Our channel was the second to
unblind, starting at 3:30 PM.
We saved the slides
onto a flash disk
and walked quickly towards
the conference room.
So we arrived.
Fabian opened the door.
A hot current flowed out.
The room was packed
with CMS colleagues.
All the seats were taken.
Many colleagues sat on the
floor or stood against the wall.
There are probably also hundreds
of colleagues connecting
through the video link.
Good luck, said he,
one of the good lucks
I have received from my
colleagues since the morning.
I carried the slides
and moved slowly
through the field
of my colleagues.
My body got heavier and
heavier as the lives
of more and more people
connected to my own.
My teammates always gave
me the strongest support,
my Higgs to two photons
colleagues striving together
on the unblinding night,
and the entire group
having worked extremely hard
together since last year.
Representing them, I was going
to unblind our Higgs search
results.
The CMS colleagues, having
worked on different stages
and aspects of the experiment
during the past 20 years,
leading to the final data
analysis for the Higgs search
from design, construction,
commission, to operation,
from hardware, software, to
computing, from data taking,
calibration, reconstruction,
to validation.
The colleagues working on
the different Higgs search
channels trying to
answer the same question,
and the colleagues working on
the different physics topics,
from the precision measurements
within the standard model
to the search beyond
the standard model,
all trying to deepen and
enlarge the same drawing
of fundamental particle physics.
Many of them were in this room
or on the video link waiting
to see and to listen
to the results.
The Atlas colleagues working
towards the same goal,
the Large Hadron
Collider's providing
the most powerful and
intense proton beans,
the generations of
experimental particle
physicists search
for the Higgs boson,
the theoretical
physicists whose work
led to the prediction
of this particle
about half a century ago,
and all the physicists
from the experimental
and the theoretical sides
working together to reach
the current understanding
of the fundamental components
of matter and force
over the past 100 years,
and all the human beings
craving to understand
nature and ourselves,
asking and searching across
the vast space and time.
Some of us got together in
this space at this time.
The Higgs to two photon
presentation was starting.
My heart was beating violently.
My mind was calm.
Please, everybody, get ready
for the next 15 minutes.
These 15 minutes would become
a part of our common memories.
Please let me quickly show you a
couple of minutes from these 15
minutes.
Since there's no sound, so I'll
just to show you very quickly.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[INAUDIBLE]
So please everybody, get
ready for the next 15 minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
Hope it's exciting
and enjoyable.
OK, not very exciting.
This is the limit for the 2011.
But the next one is
the limit for the 2012.
[LAUGHTER]
-Everybody quiet now.
-Everybody quiet, OK.
OK, this is the true unblinding.
One, two, three,
[INAUDIBLE] OK, so this
is what we see in the
2012 [INAUDIBLE] analysis.
I don't list a number here.
You can see this by eye.
And this is the combined limit
for the 2011 and the 2012.
And I'm going to show you the
p-value in the next slides.
OK, so this is the
significance of the 2012.
The black is the
combined significance.
The red is for the type
[INAUDIBLE] category.
And the rest, which are very
difficult to see by eye,
is for different categories.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
is on the next slide,
which is the combined result
of the 2011 and the 2012.
OK, so this is the
p-value of 2011 and 2012.
This black one, this
is the combined.
You can see it's beyond
[INAUDIBLE], one, two, three,
and four.
[LAUGHTER]
The [INAUDIBLE] is for
[INAUDIBLE], and the magenta--
[END PLAYBACK]
MINGMING YANG: The
unblinded two-photon results
giving the first convincing
evidence of the existence
of a new particle.
Night of that day, CERN
building two, fourth floor.
We just experienced a historic
moment, said Christoph.
Yes, we did.
Not just in the
history of science.
I did not speak out.
What else do I still
remember during that day?
This smiles from the
bottom of everyone's heart.
Our final results
continue showing
an excess around 125
GeV, which, combined
with all the other
Higgs channels,
gave the significance of
excess reach five sigma,
the conventional criteria
to claim the discovery
of a new particle.
In the same time,
a similar excess
was also observed from
the Atlas experiment.
On July 4, 2012,
both experiments
announced the discovery
of a new particle at CERN
in a joint seminar with
the 36th International
Conference of
High-Energy Physics, held
at Melbourne, Australia.
And you can see our
final plots showing
both the signal and the
significance of the excess.
And you can also
see the pictures
at the bottom showing the
situation in the auditorium
at CERN on that day.
Fabian was taking a night
shift, and he didn't make it
to the auditorium, and we
didn't stop working on that day.
And we did not have too
much time to celebrate, just
except for taking a
couple of beers together.
The world started swirling
while we kept working.
The center of a storm
was always quiet.
We didn't get any award,
but we have already
get the best award
from nature itself.
After discovery, we
continued to verify
the observation of
the new particle
and measure its properties
and check its compatibility
with the Higgs boson.
On June 15, 2015, I
submitted my PhD thesis,
which concluded the journey
that I had experienced
with my teammates and colleagues
with the stand-alone discovery
of the Higgs boson through
the two-photon channel.
And I have been
traveling since then,
and writing this
story, "The Discovery."
I want to share you the
end part of this story.
This is the end of my story of
searching for the Higgs boson.
During my travel from my
hometown to edge of Alaska,
I have encountered
different people on
the road-- high school
student, bookshop staff,
elementary school teacher,
businessman, piano technician,
taxi driver, probation officer,
raspberry farmer, plumber,
mechanic, air flight controller,
coffee shop worker, lawyer,
writer, art gallery host,
firefighter, painter, drummer,
aerial silk dancer, gold
miner, single-handed sailor,
fisherman.
It is my pleasure to share with
them the Higgs search story
and listen to their stories
back, and find how similar
the story of fisherman searching
for the salmon at Bering Sea
to our story of search for the
Higgs boson among the data sea.
The hardship, the
friendship, the passion,
and the feeling of
the power and beauty
of nature-- after
all, human activities
share the same common ground.
And I'm glad to receive
a small toy occasionally,
in a red Alaska crab
from 9-year-old Jenna.
Sometimes I'm asked,
what is the significance
of searching for the Higgs
boson to me and to human beings?
I have been thinking about
these questions myself
when walking on the road between
CERN and Saint-Genis-Pouilly,
when writing my thesis, and
when s sitting on the train.
I still remember a
conversation with Christoph
at CERN, building 32,
fourth floor, in 2011.
I told him that no matter
whether we make a discovery
or not, and whether I
would get a PhD or not,
I would never regret
coming and working here.
This is my choice of life.
And I want to say the same now.
It is thrilling to have
been deeply involved
with the milestone of the
discovery of the Higgs boson.
But having worked
together with these people
in that space at that time
itself is thrilling no
matter the outcome.
To me, connecting to the
generations of physicists,
pursuing a common goal,
witnessing and devoting myself
for the monumental effort of
human beings, along with all
the colleagues,
discovering and interacting
with all the beautiful
minds and hearts,
continuously discovering myself
and feeling the deep harmony
with nature, are the
most precious parts
of the journey searching
for the Higgs boson.
All my work is not for a PhD,
and even not for the Higgs
discovery, but for life itself.
And it has already been
finished long before,
and has been contained
in all the moments.
My main motivation
to write a thesis
is to use the opportunity
to tell these people I have
worked with that I love them.
The analysis for the Higgs
search could be repeated,
but those moments and the
stories of these people
are not replaceable.
Many of the stories
are very lovely.
They probably will
never be stated.
But they have been detected
and started in my heart,
and probably only the people who
have experienced and witnessed
these stories would feel
the deepest resonance.
The [INAUDIBLE] journey
has been wonderful,
especially because
I have shared it
with some people who,
whenever I think of them,
bring hot tears to my eyes.
I would choose the same
way to spend my 20s again
and again, If i were given the
infinite chance to step back,
and infinite ways to choose.
I will continue to
discover that future
from all the uncertainties,
following the sky above me
and the road within my heart.
I hope this road will lead
to the liberation of the soul
and enrichment of the
spirit of a human being
and of human beings, as what
this Higgs search journey
should ultimately lead to.
The train keeps moving into
vast space at the front of time.
What is the ultimate reality?
Is the observed
particle the ripple
of the field slowing
down the particles
with mass such that
they could get together
to form the structures
in the universe,
including ourselves, as
described by the standard model
of particle physics?
Our understanding always
progresses with time,
and the future will unblind.
What is sure for the moment,
search for the Higgs boson
does bring us together to
experience a series of events
in that space and time,
becoming a monumental part
of our-- a fundamental
part of existence
and a monumental part
of human history.
All the information
we have obtained
from the proton-proton
collisions at the Large Hadron
Collider, along with all
the efforts of generations
of physicists and engineers
over the world, all
the sleepless nights, all
the memorable moments, all
the collisions among ourselves,
all the beautiful minds
and hearts, all the
emotions and all the stories
are folded into the results
sent towards the future,
passing through layers of time
as pairs of photons passing
through layers of
nights as what we have
received from our predecessors.
And all the
significance is already
contained in the
human activities that
connect us with each other,
with nature, and with ourselves.
At this moment, my
heart has already
melted into infinite
pairs of protons
colliding at infinite points
in that space and time,
producing infinite pairs,
producing infinite number
of Higgs bosons decaying to
infinite pairs of photons,
pairing all my infinite
[INAUDIBLE] moments,
flying towards the future.
What is eternity?
Every moment is eternity.
This story is for you, and for
students and researchers who
silently devote
all of themselves
to the search for
the Higgs boson.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I was actually
at Atlas at the same time,
so it brings back
a lot of memories.
I was in the BSM Higgs group.
So I just wondered
your opinion about,
what was your feeling
towards the Higgs being
more or less stand model like?
Did you have any
thoughts about that?
MINGMING YANG: The Higgs
boson is more standard model
like is one good way that it
makes the standard model itself
consistent.
And that means
other understanding
in that phase space of
matter and force is complete.
But at the same time,
we know that there
are many other things
we do not know.
And all we know about matter
and force actually is about 5%
in the universe, and the other
25% is so-called dark matter.
70% is called dark energy.
At this point, we do not have
much knowledge about them.
So I think this part
getting complete
gives us a stepping stone which
sets the foundation for us
to search towards the future.
So one step at a time.
AUDIENCE:So what's next
for you personally?
MINGMING YANG: The future
is contained in now.
So by asking what
is next for me,
so let me say what
is now for me.
I think for me personally,
I was extremely
focused on the search
for the Higgs boson
during the past
few years, and I'm
a little bit like
defocusing for the moment,
because searching for
the Higgs boson is
kind of in one
direction in the phase
space of human activities.
But there are many, many,
many other directions,
many, many other dimensions.
And I hope to take this
opportunity to explore.
One thing I feel is that for
me, I want to do two things.
First is I see the huge
beauty in the human activities
in the search for
the Higgs boson,
and I would like to bring
that from that phase space
to the larger phase
space of human beings,
to bring the beauty into the
consciousness of human beings.
But in the same
time, I would also
like to explore and
observe and listen
to the stories of other people
to see how can we work together
towards a future,
and which direction
that I can contribute the best
in the future to the humanity.
[APPLAUSE]